des femmes des hommes des transsexuels
de tous les âges ven de toute la France
pourzci une MRE de famille qui et que va
se trouver dans la rue sansement
économique avec des à nourrir j'arpente
les trottoirs de Marseille je suis fier
d'être prostitué je paye des impôts
comme tout citoyen
je revendique un droit et non
uneusion on veut être tranquille et on
veut pas toute la prostitution les mafia
on n veut pas
leème
dans les mains de
raisqu la police est nous demandons
qu'elle ne soit plus là malheureusement
pour elle on comprend bien leur détresse
mais les proxenettes qu'elles ont autour
d'elles qui leur prennent tout et qui
leur font faire qui leur font faire du
boulot à la chaîne pour qu'elle leur
donne tout et en plus pas très cher ça
nous bouffe notre pain la loi prévo des
papiers pourux qui dénonc
leé je travaille
je sais que bon il y a pas mal de jeunes
garçons on dire des jeunes rains qui on
des souteneurs on sait très bien que il
balanceront pas pourquoi on ESS de virer
une fois on ESS de virer deux fois aou
ave des flingues sur les temp
aujourd'hui comme toujours
deé
plus